[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt samira ist demnächst wieder bei
ihren freunden auf einer halloween party
eingeladen letztes jahr haben sie auch
schon richtig cool gefeiert und da gab
es leckere halloween snacks dieses jahr
habe ich gesagt wir nehmen auch was mit
und machen halloween preis und zwar ist
es ein feiertag also so eine art habt
teig aber eigentlich gar nicht süß
sondern eher herzhaft und die füllung
dies dafür dann etwas mehr süß wir haben
jetzt hier in erfüllung aus kürbis äpfel
und kirschen passt wirklich hervorragend
aber wenn ihr sagt du ich möchte lieber
was herzhaftes dann könnte auch eine
hackfleisch füllung zum beispiel machen
oder auch eine vegetarische füllung also
dieser teig das ist einfach ein teil der
schmeckt komplett neutral und den könnt
ihr dann später süß oder herzhaft eben
verwenden
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
dafür für den teig verwende ich 450
gramm mehl einen teelöffel zucker einen
teelöffel salz drei teelöffel kokosöl
225 gramm eiskalte butter 60 milliliter
eiskaltes wasser und zwei teelöffel
zitronensaft
ich stelle jetzt den teig her und da ist
ganz wichtig dass alle zutaten sehr kalt
sind ich stelle auch die butter immer
für eine halbe stunde in den
gefrierschrank so ist sie wirklich
eiskalt und auch das wasser ist eiskalt
und beim teig mache ich jetzt gerne so
ich bereits im mixer zu ihr könnt auch
eine küchenmaschine oder ein
handrührgerät verwenden wichtig ist nur
dass eben die zutaten nicht lange
geknetet werden damit der teig eben auch
schön kalt bleibt jetzt gebe ich erst
mal das mehl salz und zucker
die zutaten verrühren ganz kurz
jetzt kommt das kokosöl rein
[Musik]
die butter in stückchen
geben hier den deckel drauf und kann
jetzt die puls taste drücken also ich
vermisse das ganze jetzt nicht auf
einmal sondern nur immer mal wieder so
dass nach butter stückchen zu sehen sind
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse ganz fröhlich wie
man jetzt hier sehen kann
jetzt kommt das eiskalte wasser dazu und
noch der zitronensaft und davon zwei
teelöffel
und jetzt wieder nur vorsichtig
pulsieren eben deswegen damit der teig
nicht warm wird beim zu schnellen kneten
rühren
den teig nehme ich jetzt und gebe ihnen
hier auf die arbeitsfläche und drücken
dann einfach mit den händen ein bisschen
zusammen
und danach muss ich ihnen für zwei
stunden kühl und die zeit kann ich dann
ganz gut nutzen um die füllung
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
für die füllung verwende ich 150 gramm
braunem zucker 200 milliliter kirschsaft
200 gramm äpfel 250 gramm kokain ok bis
250 gramm kirschen aus dem glas einen
teelöffel zitronensaft etwas wenn ihr
extrakt eine prise salz und hier noch
die gewürze muskatnuss zimt und ingwer
zwei teelöffel stärke und zwei esslöffel
wasser tschäppät sp die füllung eine
füllung aus äpfeln kürbis und kirche
ausgedacht wenn jetzt aber sagt ich mag
keine kürbis dann nach den einfach weg
könnte mehr äpfel nehmen oder ihr könnt
einfach alle zutaten miteinander
austauschen
hauptsache er kommt später wieder aufs
gleiche gesamtgewicht ich nehme jetzt
die äpfel und schäle sie entferne in der
mitte das kerngehäuse und kann an den
apfel schön fein würfeln
ich habe jetzt so ein paar braune
stellen dass es wahrscheinlich weil der
abwehrmann runtergefallen ist aber sie
könnte einfach wegschneiden und den
gesamten apfel dann weiter benutzen den
restlichen
[Musik]
den hokkaido kürbis finde ich ganz
praktisch weil man ähnlich schälen muss
also damit die schale auch richtig schön
weich und ich brauche davon jetzt nur
250 gramm
den rest kann ich dann einfach klein
schneiden und entweder eine suppe daraus
kochen oder ich kann es auch als püree
verarbeitet und portionsweise einfrieren
also das ist auch immer ganz praktisch
wenn man jetzt nicht immer gleich den
ganzen kürbis braucht
[Musik]
jetzt geht es direkt ans verarbeiten der
füllung gebe es zuerst den braunen
zucker in einen topf und lass ihn darin
karamellisieren
[Musik]
während der zucker karamellisiert kann
ich schon mal ich hier weiter machen und
zwar presse ich jetzt direkt auch den
zitronensaft zu den äpfeln und zum
kürbis dazu
dann kommen da die gewürze mit rein
ingwer zimt ein bisschen salz und
muskatnuss frisch gerieben muskat passt
immer gut zu erfüllen und zum kürbis ist
echt super lecker war wirklich nur eine
kleine prise vanille extrakt
und die kirchen die kann ich auch schon
einrühren
das riecht jetzt unglaublich lecker also
richtig so kürbis gewürz gibt es auch in
amerika dieses pumpkins preis und das
haben wir jetzt einfach selber kurz
zusammen gemischt und dann kann ich hier
noch in der separaten schüssel wasser
und stärke führen
die zutaten brauche ich dann nämlich zum
binden damit die füllung später einfach
ein bisschen abgebunden werden kann auch
nicht so flüssig ist
zucker karamellisiert jetzt gerade
richtig schön da muss man natürlich
aufpassen dass er nicht verbrennt und
jetzt ganz vorsichtig direkt mit dem
tier schafft ablöschen
[Musik]
mit der karamell immer erst mal ein
bisschen fest wegen dem kalten wasser
aber gleich löst sich wieder alles auf
jetzt kommt hier das ganze obst mit rein
mit dem kürbis
ich glaube das wird so ein rezept damals
sogar dem rad ist und der macht ihr
eigentlich gar keine kürbis jetzt lasse
ich die zutaten aufkochen gibt ja auch
den deckel drauf damit der kürbis schön
reich wird und die äpfel schön zu kochen
und lass das ganze dann bei niedriger
temperatur für etwa 15 minuten köcheln
schauen wir mal rein ich habe eben schon
geprüft ob der kürbis weiches das ist
nämlich ganz wichtig und jetzt gebe ich
hier diese stärke mischung rhein zum
binden und lass das ganze dann nochmal
einmal kurz aufkochen
das riecht schon richtig lecker und es
schmeckt auch unglaublich lecker und die
farbe passt perfekt zu halloween
jetzt kurz nur minuten köcheln lassen
und damit schon ein dect und entwickler
könnt ihr die füllung jetzt zu lassen
oder ihr zerstampft sind noch ein
bisschen ich hab jetzt keine stampfer da
deswegen nicht einfach die bürger presse
und zerstört und bisschen die füllung
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die füllung umfüllen
abdecken und abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der pike gut durch gekühlt und
ich habe ihn jetzt auch schon mal gut
durchgeknetet aber wirklich nur einmal
kurz damit gut aus rollen kann
und jetzt heute eben einfach auf drei
millimeter stärke aus das geht am besten
mit hölzern
sie legt hier rechts und links davon
bisschen mehr und dann mit einem großen
langen ausgestoppt rüber und wenn ihr
diese tiger nicht habt dann könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch ganz einfach im
baumarkt holzer kaufen und die
zuschneiden lassen und das wirklich auch
in jeder stärke
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier tat formen die mit
hebe boden damit ich einfach später die
tat hat er kommt raus bekommen
jetzt könnt ihr entweder eine große tat
machen oder eine mittelgroße oder auch
viele kleine ich mache jetzt einfach
beides also mit die große und kleine so
kann ich nämlich auch verschiedene
gesichter machen nämlich hier einfach
einen ausstecher ihr könnt auch ein glas
nehmen oder ein anderes gefäß sollte ein
bisschen größer sein als die tat form
dann ausstechen
die tat form ein bisschen einsprühen mit
back trends break und dann den teig
hineinlegen so ein bisschen am rand
hochdrücken und da müssen jetzt einfach
nur daran denken dass er jeweils einen
teig für den boden braucht und einen
dann für den deckel also am besten auch
direkt den zweiten ausstechen und zur
seite legen so könnte auch mit der teig
mehl ganz gut arbeiten
[Musik]
ich habe für uns zu bringen die doppelte
menge an teig gemacht denn ich mag noch
ein paar klicks daraus
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr hier die gesichter
rein machen und zwar nehme ich jetzt
dafür einfach noch tun und kleine
ausstecher und damit könnt ihr zum
beispiel gespenster gesichter machen
oder kürbisse oder auch einen totenkopf
und falls ihr sagt oder den start habe
ich jetzt keine lust könnt ihr auch
einfach die aussteller wieder benutzen
und damit in der mitte was ausstechen
habt ihr gleichzeitig einen keks und
auch direkt was schönes halloween lesen
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich die abgekühlte füllung und
der kommt jetzt einfach mitten rein
nicht so voll
denn der tankdeckel muss ja auch gleich
noch trauen sieht irgendwie es im
herzhaft auswendig aber es ist sie aber
man könnte diesen den parketts machen
mit so einer füllung
[Musik]
die tankdeckel die hatte ich jetzt noch
mal kurz im gefrierschrank damit ihr
nicht so weiß er noch nicht so schön
hoch nehmen kann
jetzt kommen die hier drauf werden
leicht angedrückt und dann bestreite ich
sie vor den bug nur noch mal mit etwas
eigelb und mit dem eiweiß bestreichen
dann einfach die kekse und gestreute
dann noch mit zimt zucker oder ihr könnt
auch die kekse dann wenn ihr möchtet
herzhaft gestalten und zb parmesan oder
kräuter darauf streuen
[Musik]
und das eigelb verrühren einfach mit
etwas wasser
so wird so ein bisschen dünner und ich
kann die preis besser damit bestreichen
[Musik]
und die kekse bestreite ich jetzt mit
ein bisschen eiweiß und streut dann
etwas zimt zucker darüber
[Musik]
und jetzt können sie schon in den
backofen echt gruselig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sehen die snacks aus und mir gefallen
so richtig gut bei den keks und muss ich
sagen dürfte beim zucker echt nicht
sparen weil er der teig wirklich eher
salzig schmeckt süß und wenn die richtig
süß sein wollen dann müsste schon
ordentlich zum zucker drauf kommt also
ich kann mich gar nicht entscheiden was
ich cola filmt die kleinen oder die
großen die kleinen sind toll weil sie
sehr handlich sind und man bekommt ja
auch wunderbar aus der tat vom raus und
deswegen liebe ich auch diese tat vor
mit hebel boden geht echt von ganz
alleine fast
das ist der poltergeist die geister und
ich mache jetzt noch ein bisschen
glitzer schnee drauf weil wirklich auch
die füllung dies zwar ein bisschen süß
aber ein bisschen zucker auf der
oberfläche ist auch nicht schlecht
ich glaube dass geister bei uns im haus
ich probiere jetzt einfach mal falls ihr
das rezept nach machen wollt dann geht
auch sallys - blog da steht es noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß dabei falls ihr die halloween preis
nach macht dann kostet es auf jeden fall
und ich werde euch ich werde mir die
bilder anschaut
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
hmm die stimme auf die suche nach dem
geist
[Musik]
einfach so der wein ist reif
normalerweise mag ich ja gerne süße
sachen aber zum wein passt doch was
schönes herzhaft ist sally zaubert neue
kreationen für ein weinfest am herz auf
gut backen kann man viel mehr
improvisieren zwiebelkuchen gemüse tat
und kies traditionelles einfach mal
anders unser gespannt ob es gut ankommt
einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr bei vox